So everybody's seen the green chemistry principles over and over.
And of course there's the one that gets right to the heart of what we're talking
about designing for energy efficiency.
So the idea that the chemist has some responsibility to recognize the impacts
that arise from their choices of the chemicals and chemical processes.
So things like this is a little bit focusing on the manufacturing stuff,
but this could also apply to raw materials and how you,
uh,
you know,
disassemble or recycled product.
If you're doing things at room temperature,
room pressure,
you're kind of giving yourself a step in the right direction.
If something has to be done and under vacuum under a really high pressure,
really high temperature,
then you're,
uh,
you've got to challenge cut out for you.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
there have been pressures on a energy resources for many,
many years.
Um,
you know,
at,
at times society has been sort of more an agreement about the best way to deal
with it.
But,
um,
the reasons why we're concerned about it and I have to do with all these other
impacts,
they're all inextricably linked to each other.
So the energy choices lead to a co two emissions.
I think pretty much everybody agrees,
even if they disagree on the timeline of when,
uh,
fossil resources are going to be depleted,
I think it's pretty unambiguous that they are being depleted at a rate faster
than we can replenish them.
Uh,
the toxicity issues.
So a lot of fuels that we are,
or crude,
uh,
energy materials that we extract from the earth or not in pure form.
And then we'll,
we're bringing up nitrogen sulfur along with the carbon.
This gets introduced to ecosystems work that are not used to dealing with it.
I'm going to spend a lot of the later part of the lecture talking about the
energy water connections because these are really easy to quantify and uh,
they,
they really are kind of linked in a feedback cycle that the more energy use,
the more water you use and vice versa.
The more water you use takes more energy to produce,
uh,
the water.
Uh,
and then there are the waste issues as well.
So,
um,
some of the obvious ones being nuclear waste to have to deal with the waste
materials that are generated.
And then there's also issues of just wasted energy.
So we,
I think we saw some of these charts in the very beginning of the class,
but I think it would be useful to revisit them.
So despite all the,
um,
efforts to focus on energy conservation,
the trend is very clearly in the opposite direction.
And we saw a lot of hockey stick curves at the beginning of class and that kind
of drives the,
the increase in energy.
So we're here somewhere between these two bars,
but,
uh,
we're pretty,
inextricably on this upward curve right now.
So there's this constant demand for more and more energy.
So if we look at the energy sources,
yeah,
of course we see the same trend broadly.
Uh,
where are we get energy from there.
There's liquids,
so essentially petroleum,
fractions,
coal,
it's always been one of the big ones,
natural gas,
renewables,
and then nuclear power.
This data is from 2008.
Um,
of course a lot of things have happened since 2008.
We had a pretty big recession that,
uh,
I looked up some more recent numbers and basically that just kind of flat lined
a little bit for a couple of years and then resumed the upward curve.
So if you can just imagine this stretched out by two or three years.
And then the other thing is that of course with the,
um,
the rise in natural gas production in the u s that,
the natural gas and some of the liquids have bumped up a little bit and Cole was
gone down just a little bit.
But for the most part,
these trends have held pretty well to predictions.
So just keep an eye on these numbers quadrillions and BTUs cause it will be
important on some of the later slides.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is a very,
uh,
there's a lot of information and this chart,
so I'll,
I'll go through this a little bit slowly.
This comes out of the,
one of the national labs in the U S so we're looking just at US energy use.
So,
uh,
97 quad squad is a quadrillion Btu.
So if I go back for a second,
uh,
total world consumption,
if we start adding up some of these numbers,
like one 50,
250,
300,
something like three or 400 quad.
So it looks like the u s is using close to 25% of the world's energy.
Um,
you'll probably find a more precise number than that.
But ballpark,
that's where we are.
So on this side we have all the different sources.
Uh,
it's broken down a little bit more specifically then the last slide because
they've separated out some of the renewables.
Now we have solar,
hydro,
wind,
geothermal are separated.
And then over on this side we have the,
the major sectors,
so residential use of energy,
commercial use of energy,
industrial.
So this is going to be a largely responsible to chemical production and in this
set right here,
and then transportation.
And then the last thing they've added here,
which is what's kind of a surprise to me.
The first time I saw this is how much energy actually gets used as opposed to
what gets wasted.
So,
uh,
roughly,
50 to 60% of all the energy that's produced is not used productively.
It just goes to waste heat.
So our infrastructure is actually very inefficient.
So even if some of these industries are,
are doing well with their,
their efficiencies,
uh,
the actual production itself is not.
So that bares out in what professor and asked us was just saying that the
industrial complex is using the vast majority of the energy that comes in.
So their waste bar is fairly low.
But if you look at something like electricity generation,
uh,
by far the vast majority of that's going to waste.
And so this has to do with the technology that's installed at power plants right
now.
So,
um,
waste heat is probably the biggest thing that nuclear reactors,
all these different reactors,
they are generating Pete in addition to the electricity.
So all of that energy is going to be rejected.
Uh,
we talked a lot about energy.
This is another really dense graph.
Mckinsey is very good at doing,
putting a lot of information on one slide.
So I'll also try and walk through this,
um,
here.
Uh,
first one,
I'll start with axes.
So this,
they're,
they're trying to calculate what sort of a known energy efficient technologies
could be put into practice today to achieve some efficiency gains.
And so if you add up all these different ideas that they have for saving
electricity or saving energy,
then the total value of that energy would be 9,500,
uh,
trillion btu.
So that's 9.5 quadrillions nine and a half quads,
energy use,
97 quads.
So in the u s alone,
so Mckinsey has identified ideas for about 10% of our energy usage.
So this is kind of the low hanging fruit.
So,
you know,
it's great that there's a lot of efficient technology out there and there's some
things that people have ideas about to,
um,
to put it put in practice to,
to save a little bit more.
But we still got this other 90% of the pie that needs a lot of work.
So besides the efficiencies,
there's just that,
the magnitude of the whole thing,
there's a lot of energy being used and uh,
you know,
efficiency is going to get you a little bit of the way,
but we have to go back and start thinking about some of these,
uh,
intrinsic processes that are leading to the,
to the overall big piece of the Pie.
So I think the last point I wanted to make,
you're a,
it took me a couple of minutes to find these and the nest of information here,
chemical processes is right here.
That's this little sliver right there.
So Mckinsey has identified this little sliver sliver as being kind of low
hanging fruit for improving a chemical processes.
There were a couple others that were really related to chemistry.
So cement production,
definitely chemistry in there,
and then a pulp and paper processes.
It gets a little bit of a bar there.
So,
uh,
those are kind of the major chemistry,
a centered processes that are in his overall energy curve.
So that's really kind of a drop in the bucket compared to the actual energy use.
So
that means there's a lot of work that needs to be done to go further,
because this,
this little bit of low hanging fruit is not going to get us far in terms of the
overall energy impacts.